screenwriters expend a lot of time and
effort to craft perfect scripts however
some of the silver screens most
memorable lines were actually ad-libbed
by the actors there were many to choose
from but we've gathered a dozen of the
best improvise moments in movie history
to share with you one of the delights of
making a movie with experienced
comedians trained in improv is that
you're going to end up with a whole lot
of surprises and because everyone is
accustomed to thinking on their toes
these bits of improvisation can end up
going pretty far out there
bridesmaids open the door for a new
breed of raunchy female oriented
romantic comedies that broke the mold
for the genre and some of its most
memorable scenes were improvised there
was so much ad-libbing that director
Paul Feig prepared for it by using two
cameras for many of the one-on-one
scenes so he could capture and cut
together both reactions many of Melissa
McCarthy's over-the-top moments during
the dress fitting scene as well as her
banter with the air marshal on the plane
were all unscripted but the improv
winner and bridesmaids as a horrible and
hilarious scene where bride-to-be Lily
and played by Maya Rudolph makes an
unexpected stop in the middle of the
streets after getting food poisoning
it's happening
didn't happen
this unscripted and perfectly timed
moment caught the cinematographer by
surprise as much as it did the audience
Matthew McConaughey has built an
impressive filmography over the years
but no matter how many Awards he wins
he'll never escape the simple words he
had said during 1993
dazed and confused it's become one of
the movie's most quoted lines a
McConaughey improvised it on the spot
the actor claimed so based a line on a
Nutter runs by doors frontman Jim
Morrison during a live performance of
the song Roadhouse blues as repeated by
McConaughey's character career stoner
David Wooderson the line became a
catchphrase on set in fact it showed up
twice in the film
the casting crew even started using a
tough camera and has since become one of
McConaughey's signature lines in real
life
he even revisited it in his Academy
Award speech for best actor Viggo
Mortensen is well known for his method
acting skills and films like Eastern
Promises on the road during which he
insisted on doing his own stunt work and
fight scenes what he didn't go for
method while filming the Lord of the
Rings trilogy he would often ride his
horse and hike alone to the next filming
location however there was one scene in
the two towers where Mortensen channeled
actual physical pain into his
performance in the first part of the
movie
Pip and Mary are held captive by a band
of orcs and Aragorn is desperately
trying to save them when he thinks
they've been killed he takes his anger
out on a nearby helmet the unscripted
moments of Aragorn yelling and falling
to his knees wasn't method acting it was
serious pain this was a fifth take of
the scene immortan son broke two toes
when he kicked the helmet
director Peter Jackson decided to keep
the scene in the movie for its raw
emotion since Mortensen didn't break
character and his reaction made complete
sense for that moment Avengers infinity
war broke box office records around the
world and it also broke viewers hearts
with the result of therosis infamous
finger snap because this was such a
big-budget film as so many moving parts
at any given time it's surprising that
that would have been room for any
improvisation at all that's alone in
some incredibly poignant and important
scenes for example most of the snarky
exchange between star-lord and Thor was
ad-libbed the scene where Captain
America points out health or copied his
beard was also improvised by the two
actors even dave bautista as Drax had an
off-the-cuff response to Iron Man Oh
who's Gamora oh do you want better why
is Gamora however one crushing moment of
improv particularly stands out in the
Russo brothers script spider-man's final
words were just supposed to be I don't
feel so good and I'm sorry but actor Tom
Holland added some heart-rending lines
to the scene
the rawness and vulnerability of the
moment are evident in Holland's
performance and in Robert Downey's
emotional reaction to this perfect
unplanned a bit of dialogue initially
some people questioned director
Christopher Nolan's decision to cast
Heath Ledger as the Joker in the Dark
Knight but Ledger's incredible
commitment to the role was evident from
the first moment he appeared on screen
Nolan is credited Ledger with coming up
with most of what made this version of
the Joker so compelling anteus widely
rumored to have improvised a couple of
the movie's classic moments after the
Joker was arrested by Detective Jim
Gordon Gotham's mayor stops by the jail
to take a look at the city's new
high-profile prisoner and promote Gordon
to Commissioner as he officers in the
room break into applause they're joined
by an allegedly improvising ledger
elsewhere in the film after his rector
hospital to explode the Joker had said
that a nation button only to be
disappointed when nothing happens
according to rumor Ledger's response was
another great moment of improvisation
Roy Scheider had many unforgettable
scenes in Jaws from frantically trying
to get beachgoers out of shark-infested
waters the taking aim and blowing up his
tooth in emesis but perhaps the most
memorable scenes of Jaws is when
Scheider is chumming the water and the
enormous great white shark pops up to
say hello
Sri Desai goes back was in shock and
hurts as this classic line but what most
people don't know is that Scheider
actually ad-lib that line numerous times
during different scenes on the film
after repeated production delays and
cost overruns threatening to sing the
entire film the line you're guaranteed a
bigger boat became an in-joke among the
cast and crew and Scheider began
randomly slipping it in the different
scenes as a gag it was so effective here
though that director Steven Spielberg
decided to keep it it's hard to believe
but one of the most famous lines of all
time almost ended up on the cutting room
floor in the 1980 film adaptation of
Stephen King's novel The Shining Jack
Nicholson had a scene where his
character was hacking through a bathroom
door with an axe when he made an opening
big enough to his face Nicholson
ad-libbed a line that would have been
known to every viewer of America
late night television here's Jeanne that
line was part of the classic opening of
The Tonight Show Starring Johnny Carson
for decades unfortunately one person who
didn't get the reference was director
Stanley Kubrick he had been living in
England so long he had no idea what
Nicholson was talking about so it just
seemed like a strange non sequitur
fortunately Nicholson's ad-lib made the
final curse and became one of the most
quoted lines out of a very quotable
career can't handle the truth I want you
to hold it between your knees will they
get low to me Harry Potter universe is
filled with magical moments and an
entire lexicon of spells based on JK
Rowling's best-selling series of books
the second installment in the movie
series the Chamber of Secrets follows
the intrepid group of young wizards and
witches as they attempt to discover who
unleashed a monster that's terrorizing
the students of Hogwarts they suspect it
has something to do with how sliver in
andis ancestors Harry and Ron and
Hermione fix up a batch of Polyjuice
potion so they can go into cover and
investigate the potion turns Harry and
Ron into Draco Malfoy's henchmen boilin
Crabbe which means I can find out if
Malfoy family might have something to do
with the base when Drakkar happens to
see them he notices right away that
Goyle is suddenly wearing glasses Coyle
Harry in disguise a sailor for reading
- which Draco responds reading I can
take a break actor Tom Felton had
forgotten his line and improvised a new
one on the spots director Chris Columbus
loved the cruelty and comedy a brought
to the scene so we left it in Harrison
Ford has taken part in plenty of classic
movie moments but a couple of his most
iconic ones were actually improvised in
the Empire Strikes Back there's a scene
of cemented Han Solo in our hearts
forever as he ultimate romantic rogue
faced with what seems like his imminent
death carrie fisher's princess leia
finally admits her love for Han his
response I know but that wasn't in the
script Palme was actually supposed to
say just remember that because I'll be
back luckily for fans across the
universe Ford thought he could do better
and delivered the line we all know and
love today then that's as perfect
wordless improvisation and Raiders of
the Lost Ark
despite rehearsing the choreography for
weeks Ford did not want to film a
lengthy sword versus whip fight scene he
came down with food poisoning the night
or shooting and simply couldn't go
through with what they'd planned you run
an idea pastor actor Steven Spielberg
that became one of the most famous
scenes on the Indiana Jones series in
When Harry Met Sally Billy Crystal's
character is driving from Chicago to New
York with his girlfriend's roommate
played by meg Ryan they definitely don't
hit it off at first but as they keep
running into each other through the
years
a friendship begins to develop directed
by Rob Reiner and written by Nora Ephron
the film is filled with one-liners about
romance
love and relationships addressing the
eternal question can men and women
really be friends considering crystal
and wine his experience with improv and
stand-up comedy it's no surprise that a
number of lines would be ad-libbed along
the way in rehearsals it was actually
Krystal who came up with the film's most
iconic line I'll have what she's having
but that's not all the entire pecan pie
discussion when harry and Sally are
walking around the museum was improvised
at one point when Krystal asked Ryan to
repeat his words she briefly breaks
character and looks off-camera at the
director then snaps right back into the
scene it was such a genuine moment that
Reiner decided to use the whole take in
the final film based on the timeless
Roald Dahl book Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory the similarly titled
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory is
a whimsical and beloved film from 1971
that has consistently enchanted and even
disturbed audience members for decades
has to be expected from a comedy legend
like Gene Wilder he had some things to
say about his character the enigmatic
Willy Wonka in particular he wanted to
introduce the Wonka's unpredictable
nature right away before he even spoke a
word
why would I propose the bait and switch
that wasn't in the script he would walk
with a limp as if he needed a cane then
spring into action
it's a memorable sequence that also
helps illustrate willy wonka's complex
personality as why would I put set from
that time on no one will know if I'm
lying or telling the truth
it doesn't seem appropriate to say that
this is spinal tap but a great ad libbed
line or two because most of the film was
improvised directed by Rob Reiner and
starring Michael McKean Christopher
Guest and Harry Shearer as members of
the band spinal tap the brilliant
mockumentary has a huge fan following
and spawned some truly classic
catchphrases these go to 11 well there
was an outline for the movie it was just
a starting point for the cast to follow
their comedic instincts whether they
were hanging out backstage performing
live on stage or even just looking for
the stage the actors of spinal tap
delivered a masterclass on improvisation
and continually reminded viewers of one
very important thing the fine line
between stupid and and clever yes check
out one of our newest videos right there
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
you